former Fox News host Bill O'Reilly vows
to speak out today against what he says
our lies in a disturbing New York Times
story The Times says the Fox News parent
company 21st Century Fox renewed
O'Reilly's multi-million dollar contract
despite knowing he had settled sexual
harassment claims against him the report
also says O'Reilly agreed to pay a
former Fox News analyst 32 million
dollars bianna golodryga is here with
all the fallout beyond good morning and
Norah good morning this would be the
total number of settlements that he's
paid out to 45 million dollars allegedly
the time says this was the largest of at
least half a dozen known settlements
made by either O'Reilly or Fox and
O'Reilly spokesperson said that his
client is one of many men accused by the
company which he says has paid close to
100 million dollars in settlements he
calls the New York Times report false
and defamatory a civil lawsuit against
the New York Times reports Bill O'Reilly
agreed to pay frequent contributor lease
Weil 32 million dollars to settle
allegations that included repeated
harassment a non-consensual sexual
relationship and the sending of gay
pornography the article says just one
month later Fox News parent company 21st
Century Fox resigned the host to a new
four-year hundred million dollar
contract over the weekend the company
issued a statement saying it was aware
of the threatened suit but was informed
by mr. O'Reilly that he had settled the
matter personally and the terms were
confidential and not disclosed to the
company criticism came from within Fox
News itself but this is a significant
setback for Fox it there's no question
about it it's embarrassing if Fox News
or any other company gets wind of a
confidential settlement albeit private
it still has an obligation now to
disclose The Times reports the
settlements with O'Reilly accusers have
totaled about forty five million dollars
O'Reilly told the paper I never
mistreated anyone adding that he
resolved matters privately because he
wanted to protect his children from the
publicity former Fox News host gretchen
carlson settled harassment claims
against the late
News chief Roger Ailes for 20 million
dollars commenting on the New York Times
report she tweeted nobody pays 32
million for false allegations
nobody will said in an affidavit
apparently signed after the settlement
that she has no claims against the
former Fox News host 21st Century Fox is
further defending itself by saying a
Riley's new contract included a clause
allowing his dismissal if the company
became aware of other relevant
information and that it could be used
that clause
against him to fire him but it's still a
lot of people questioning why would they
Reese I named for that amount of money
after knowing that these settlements
existed yeah exactly there's a question
a lot of people are asking thank you
very much Rihanna